in the aftermath of yet another air
attack firefighters attempt to douse a
blaze in yemen's capital sanaa
this after a flurry of strikes on
targets in tsuna as well as on the port
city of hodeidah which killed several
people
some residents claimed that united
nations workers in a nearby building had
prior knowledge and left the area before
the attack took place
it's strange that their staff left a few
hours ahead of the airstrike which means
that they were probably notified the
saudi-led airstrikes came a day after a
series of drone and missile attacks by
houthi rebels on jeddah and other saudi
cities all refineries were among the
targets
there were no deaths reported in the
strikes but it was the most concerted
air operation by the houthis in the
seven year conflict
and in the wake of the retaliatory
attacks by the coalition the houthi
rebels announced a unilateral three-day
ceasefire expressing the hope that it
could be extended
we unilaterally announce the suspension
of missile and drone strikes and all
military actions towards the kingdom of
saudi arabia by land sea and air for a
period of three days
we affirm our readiness to turn this
declaration into a final
firm and permanent commitment if the
kingdom of saudi arabia announces and
commits itself to ending the siege and
stopping its air raids on the territory
of the republic of yemen once and for
all
earlier in the day residents of sonar
defiantly rallied in the streets of the
capital marking seven years of a
conflict in which more than 150 000
people have been killed and one that's
created one of the world's worst
humanitarian crises
alex catopoulos al jazeera